nous sommes partis du constat que nous
avions deux narines et nous nous sommes
demandé pourquoi car nous avons deux
yeux qui permettent la vision en 3d nous
avons deux oreilles qui permettent de
localiser les sons mais pourquoi deux
narines
nous nous sommes demandés s'il y avait
une différence fonctionnelle entre ces
deux narines là donc nous avons testé
une narine après l'autre
et effectivement il y a une différence
entre les deux narines donc avec une
narine meilleur que l'autre
et cette narines meilleur que l'autre
peut être content la gauche que la
droite donc il n'y a pas dans l'ensemble
de narines meilleur entre gauche et
droite
le but ultime en fait de cette recherche
serait pouvoir aider dans les maladies
de parkinson et alzheimer car dans ces
maladies les troubles half actifs sont
très fréquents et on ne s'en rend pas
forcément compte car une narine diminue
après l'autre donc en testant les
narines séparément on pourrait détecter
cette chronique plus tôt